I paid a stranger hundreds of dollars to
create these architectural renders why
well every video on YouTube is either
sponsored by Fiverr or promoted by
another brand I wanted to be able to
provide an independent review if these
rendering artists on Fiverr are
genuinely what they say they are for
this render here I paid thirty dollars
and thirty dollars it's pretty bloody
good thirty dollars would cover maybe
one person's hourly rate for one hour so
to be able to get something like this in
one hour isn't bad if you think about it
there is quite a bit lacking here it is
a very basic basic render we have 2D
flat textures we have no 3D articulation
in the grass we have lights that are on
lights that are off we have yellow
lights versus white lights all mix
matching we have a couple cars in the
context as well as a few little plants
here and there which definitely add to
the ambience and the vibe of this image
here that I see before me but overall oh
it's pretty flat it's pretty generic and
I could have imported this into twin
motion and got an example very similar
to this in a matter of five minutes
personally speaking this 30 render do I
think it's worth it honestly most likely
not I could have done this in about five
to ten minutes so I don't think I would
have spent thirty dollars on this render
if I knew what I was going to get now I
had this exact same image rendered again
for 65 so 65 double the price double the
quality are we going to get that let's
take a look this is more than double the
quality for double the price if I'm
looking at it straight off the bat I'm
very very happy for sixty five dollars
this is an exceptional image not only
have they gone ahead and basically
redesigned the whole context and
surrounding to actually suit what's
happening in the real world straight
away just from a context point of view
this is exceptional well and truly worth
the 65 if not even more looking at the
actual render it's self they've gone
into quite a bit of context and detail
3D architectural grass 3D planting
shrubs foreground background birds as
well as Reflections and it even looks
like they put in curtains and some
furniture into the actual house itself
to give it a bit more life a bit more
character so that's actually phenomenal
65 would I pay this again absolutely I
would moving on to an interior render
now I asked both of these same 3D
artists to do one 3D render I provided
them no furniture just a basic shell
inside for thirty dollars again I think
my feedback is very very similar to what
that was of the external render for this
artist it is very generic it is very
basic very boring the lights don't match
the shadows and contrast are terrible it
looks like something out of twin motion
for five minutes worth of work so
unfortunately this 30 is not well spent
taking a look at the 65 render internal
render okay again I am very very
impressed for 65 dollars for an internal
render it is significantly better night
and day poles apart so what I'm learning
so far is if you pay a very small amount
of money you're going to be able to
expect a very average result however
paying that little bit more is
significantly worth it this internal
render is phenomenal now this is
something I'd expect to get out of 3ds
Max or a high-end architecture rendering
software you can see some beautiful Suns
and Shadows coming in you can see the
texture is very high quality you can
even see that they've gone ahead and
modeled the background outside of this
window once again providing even more
context to make this seem like a good
render the chairs aren't perfectly
aligned so it looks like somebody's
using the space living here we've got
food on the table we don't have any
Cutlery to eat the food but that's okay
we've got some plants some vases some
ornamental features and decorations that
most likely people would use in their
real home there is some downsides to
this render even though it is top end
and I'm actually very satisfied with it
what we are seeing here in front of us
is the ceiling has a very very strange
texture there is no other lighting
except this feature pendant at the
foreground so there's no down lights
anywhere else the strip lighting in the
living room and in the kitchen seems
like a bit of an Overkill it shouldn't
be on during the day it does add a
little bit of warmth a little bit of a
nice character to it but I don't think
it required it personally speaking
overall it is an exceptionally well done
render and I think that again is worth
65 now I wanted to move on to something
a little bit more challenging something
in the actual environment so this is a
small apartment building next to a
Heritage building directly in front of
it starting off with this 30 exterior
render it isn't half bad look I'm going
to give it a bit more credit than I gave
that residential home we have a bit more
context and character they've included a
fence which I didn't model but all of
the extra surroundings like the white
boxes in the background were from the
archicad model I can tell it is from
Twin motion because I know that
background is very very generic very
twin motion the sky is again
exceptionally repetitive from that last
image and there isn't too much
foreground background happening here it
is a very stilted image overall for
thirty dollars because the project is so
big I think it's worth it I wouldn't be
too displeased if I received this image
for 30 or if somebody told me it was
only going to take them an hour to do
overall not too bad now we're moving up
to an image that costs three and a bit
more than the original image so I'm
expecting to see something exceptional
once again we have a lot more going on
and again it is worth the extra money so
looking at this 100 image first of all
they've included the full context again
we have foot Parts curbs Road manhole
covers we have power lines power poles
we have that full context it feels like
we're standing on site right now looking
at this building it is a little bit more
artistic than I would have liked I would
have appreciated a bit more photo
realism it is probably a little bit too
cinematic with the greens coming into
the shadows and the teal colors in the
actual color grading itself nonetheless
it is very very good we have furniture
modeled upstairs in that rear apartment
with curtains and plants people and a
beanbag chair we have cars parked in the
background of the car parking we even
the man with a little bit of motion blur
walking through this image is exactly
what you'd expect from a high-end
architectural photo so they're really
calling upon cues of architectural
photography to be able to produce some
great architectural renders last but not
least we have a small hotel the first
render cost me fifty dollars and what I
got back out out of it he's is slightly
disappointing to be honest we have no
background up in the back left hand
corner we have water puddles all over
this it looks like it's been raining and
flooded we have dead debris all over the
front of the actual property which
doesn't look like it's being maintained
and somewhere I'd like to stay it's got
power poles and lines that just look
like they've been plonked there bushes
at the top that look like they're
floating some very strange bright orange
happening in this picture which is
originally just meant to be some bronze
feature which it's come out as a very
sharp contrast would I be happy with
this as a 50 render
no because I had to pay for it would I
be happy if somebody in the office
produced this as a quick one hour render
or a half an hour render to just provide
the client some basic information yes I
would be happy with this as a very
starting point but not as a marketing
image so I think for fifty dollars for
something of a project of this scale I'm
probably being a little bit too harsh it
is very decent it gives you the general
idea you understand it's black whites
oranges where the cars drive through and
where things are in relation to the
actual crossover overall would I try and
use this image for anything other than a
very quick conversation with a client
absolutely not now this last image cost
me 78 or 28 dollars more only 50 more
than what we just saw I'm seeing 500
million times better results not only do
we see a little bit more of a realistic
shot we see the footpath the cross over
the roads again the context that really
sells the story even the palm trees that
we see in this image are genuinely palm
trees on this site they've introduced a
small little building to the right hand
side which is there on site it does
exist there isn't this overwhelming
orange all over the building it is a
subtle bronze contrast against the
charcoal finishes that was the original
architectural tension
so this image this image is something I
would like to show to a client I would
like to present on social media and I
would use time and time again because it
is a high quality image compared to that
for what I got for just 28 less so that
is four Images compared side by side for
the cheap renderer to the expensive
renderer on Fiverr again this video was
not sponsored by Fiverr so therefore it
is a very honest and non-biased review
personally I do hope you enjoyed this
video if you did make sure you check out
the playlist to the side of me for some
more great architectural content and if
you really love the video I'd appreciate
it if you smash that like And subscribe
button down below but like always I'll
see you next Monday